hi
ibasu and today i'm going to be telling
you
about synonymic tools that have come
online are recently
being used biology and for the treatment
of human disease
i am an assistant professor at the
genetic medicine
section in the department of medicine in
university of chicago
and also a staff scientist at argonne
national lab
in the center for nanoscale materials
the idea is to build new devices
new imaging and new materials
and bring them to medicine both for
genetics
and in general
so i i'm going to start with
expression gene expression in complex
tissues and i'm going to point out
that we have the same
dna in our whole body but we perform
many many different functions we have
many different cell types
uh for example in the brain we have a
hundred billion
cells and uh at least a thousand
uh different uh neuronal cells
that does the different function and
that is just for the brain for the rest
of the body there is an
uh enormous com complexity in cell types
and functions that exist
how does this uh happen it happens
through
gene expression so with the same set of
gn
dna in all the cells we have different
parts of the dna
expressed which is
expressed in the form of rna messenger
rna
and they go on to produce proteins which
are
the actual functional uh part of the
cells and that is how the cell performs
its function
or displays its phenotype
so we are going to classify different
cell types
by gene expression so that can be done
in many different ways
by looking at rna for example it is easy
because
uh rna is um
is expressed uh to a larger extent many
more copies of the rna
than the two copies of
dna that is present you could also be
looking at the proteins in a given cell
or you could be looking at the parts of
the dna that are
accessible for transcription or for
gene expression we are going to be
talking
mainly about messenger rna or rna
we are going to be talking not just
about profiling
singles for their gene expression but we
are also going to
talk about throughput uh it is not
enough to look at
uh single cells but it is very important
to look at many
cells uh household cells tons of
parallels
if we are to understand the complex
nature
of these uh tissues like the brain the
immune system
a complex tumor micro environment for
example
and um in the very beginning uh
around about uh 2013-14 when single cell
experiments were becoming um a norm and
the
field was adapting it one of the
challenges in
scaling this kind of single cell
sequencing technique was
uh throughput how could we perform uh
many cells in parallel and how could we
reduce cost
now we are all aware of the high cost of
sequencing dna sequencing and there is
also uh uh uh in parallel a very high
cost of preparing these uh
uh cells ready for uh the kind of
sequencing that
uh the the field does these days so we
had to
perform uh many experiments at the same
time and also be
uh cognizant of the cost and for that
uh the technique that got very uh
popular was
emulsion microfluidics these are uh
little droplets of water in oil um
where these uh water droplets serve as
reaction compartments
so you can imagine each water droplet as
a test tube an individual test tube and
if you were to
do a 10 000 cell experiment
you have to generate 10 000 such
compartments
10 000 such water droplets this was done
by using microfluidic devices
and using water and oil emulsion
these i'm going to be referring to this
as droplet microfluidics
the other thing that we needed to do was
to do
uh to assign labels to each of these
water uh uh droplets uh or our reaction
compartments
so if we had a cell in each of these
cells we had in each of these droplets
there was a necessity to uh attach
a
droplets or two of the cell in a given
droplet
and this is uh traditionally
done or mostly done with dna barcoding
though there are other
options of doing this for example
fluorescent barcoding
we are going to be using a fluorocarbon
oil which is
heavier than water it's very low
viscosity
it is also pretty
compatible with cells with living cells
and we add a surfactant to these uh
droplets or to these um water
oil emulsion system so that
we can have these droplets be stable for
long periods of time
so what we have here is a microfluidic
uh device generated water and oil system
um the uh picture to the very right
here water droplets getting um uh
genera uh getting uh generated in an oil
background
um these are uh uh stabilized
using a surfactant which
uh is uh goes to the interface of the
water and the oil
are droplets and stabilizes it for
not only long periods of time you can
have these droplets be stable
for months at room temperature but is
also stable under thermocycling
so in order to do pcr for example
it is possible to do thermocycling and
still have the droplets
maintain their integrity it is possible
to grow cells in them so if you were to
load these cells and do incubation you
could also do that
so it is not just uh useful for doing
single cell genomic applications but
this
uh reverse emulsion system is good for a
variety of other purposes
also which i'm not going to go into but
is a field in itself
um and and to mention uh the dna
barcoding that i had
talked about earlier that is necessary
to uh
label each of these cells we assign
a dna rna that we get from these cells
so for example
if we are interested in the messenger
rna we are going to attach
this dna barcode to the messenger rna if
if we were to look at a dna particular
dna fragment from the cell we would
attach this
uh dna barcode to that dna fragment
the unique thing about this dna barcode
is that it has
a um a series of uh
js here if you look to the bottom uh of
the
slide uh in in blue this
is going to be unique for every droplet
so each a cell that is assigned to a
given droplet is going to have its own
unique barcode
there is also a sequence called
umi or universal molecular identifier
that is
uh going to be unique to each messenger
rna
that lets us do uh rna counting
and there is also a section of poly
polytease here
that is going to select out the
messenger rna so mammalian or
eukaryotic messenger rnas have
a sequence of a's on the end of the
messenger rna molecule
the poly a of the poly t select
allows us to select out the messenger
rna from all the other types of rna that
is present
i should mention that the mrna is a
small frame that is present they are
also very informative
but not for the purposes of classifying
cell types
so we are going to ignore those for the
most
part for
the technique that i am going to be
talking about mainly this
dna barcode is attached to a polystyrene
bead
actually a pmma bead
that is 40 microns in size and there are
many such dna barcodes on the surface
attached to the surface of
this bead with peg links and
uh by our estimation it is
roughly 500 million of these uh barcodes
dna barcodes that are present we have
many such beads
each bead is going to have a unique uh
cellular barcode
that's the part in blue and each one of
them is going to have a high complexity
of umis
about 500 million of such umis
roughly speaking that is going to allow
us
to capture all the rna that's present in
the million cells
so why droplet microfluidics uh there
are other ways of doing these kind of
techniques also such as microwells or
nanowells
people still do a lot of plate based
single cell sequencing a
regular plastic microwell plate for
example has
96 wells where you can easily process
96 cells what this droplet microfluidic
allows us
is to just scale up this number many
folds
not only does it allow us to scale up
the number of cells we can process at a
given time
but we can also use very very little
reagents
now people who work in biology or in
genetics
we know how costly enzymes are
this kind of scaling down of the
of the reaction compartments from 10
microliters
to say 50 nanoliters
allows us to save on reagent cost which
is important because we are doing
uh 10 000 such reactions and these
numbers quickly add up
other advantages of microfluidic channel
of microfluidic devices are that the
channel sizes the dimensions
associated with the fluid flow is very
small
and we have very low reynolds number
flow the droplet generation the
reactions that happen
are very um are happen in a laminar
fashion and there is
a lot of precision and reproducibility
in these droplets generated
the other advantage is that these
droplets get generated at very very high
speed
um you can go anywhere between kilohertz
to up to 20 kilohertz that's
20 000 droplets getting generated per
second so
uh it really helps with like reduced
batch effects for example
and of course you are you only have to
run a longer experiment
to change the number of cells that you
need to process
which is a distinct advantage
the first technique that i'm going to
talk to you about is roxy which we use
in the lab quite a bit
uh it uses this um emulsion
microfluidics
and dna barcoding technique that i
just introduced you start off with
a tissue of choice complex tissue
let's think about the brain for example
you start with a cell dissociation it
could be
mechanical enzymatic detergent based uh
you dissociate the cells this
i i'll also point out that this is the
most critical part of the entire process
you start with the cell dissociation
generate a single cell suspension such
that there isn't a lot of leaks
uh in the cell membrane you don't
damage too much during dissociation
process
uh if there are uh if the cell membranes
get leaky and damaged there will be some
amount of rna that will
leak out into the ambient solution and
that is going to
add to the noise so we have to be
cognizant about that
but we also have to make a good enough
single cell suspension such that you
know they are all
separated and cells don't stick to each
other
after this we are going to flow this
into a microfluidic device
with a dna barcode beat that i had uh
talked to you earlier
we are going to flow them in such a
fashion that there
is one cell and one barcode bead
in a given droplet this is mainly done
by adjusting the concentration of the
cells and the
barcode bead once the cells are in the
uh are encapsulated
into there is also a lysis agent that
was flown in with the
uh dna barcode beads that is going to
destabilize the cell membrane and have
the rna released into the droplet
and what is going to happen is this rna
because of the high concentration of
molecules
in a droplet it's going to find dna
barcodes that are attached to the beads
and come eyes to the poly t section that
i had shown you before
so the end result is we are going to
sample
the mrna from a given cell onto
uh using these dna barcode beads um
such that a fraction of the mrna is
uh hybridized onto the uh onto the bead
once this happens we can then break the
droplets we can then perform reverse
transcription
this can be done both inside the
droplets or also the droplets
and there are uh different techniques
that do
either or once the reverse transcription
happens
the rna gets converted into stable
cdna which are complementary dna that
has the barcode the dna barcode attached
to it
we then collect all this dna barcode and
uh dna barcoded dna and uh
you amp and make library
sequence for most of the cases uh
illumina based sequencing
and uh that that is a
or a a standard that is
uh practiced in most cases
so here we have a dropseek
device setup that is run by syringe
pumps
there is the device sitting uh the
droplets are getting generated
in the microfluidic devices where the
speeds and lysis
agents meet those are getting and
captain these droplets with the beads
and then they
flow out they are generated at 2000
droplets per second
and this is uh for your uh information
this is a 125 micron
uh device that generates about 125
micron
droplet in diameter
a couple of things that i'm going to
point out about this
uh technique is that it has pretty high
correlation with bulk
uh about 0.9 uh on a
on average we get about uh 5 000
uh uh unique genes for every cell
uh that is uh that is run
uh now this number going to change by uh
the cell phone quality
uh genes that are uh that are
being uh uh expressed uh that are
getting cycled
and that uh roughly translates to about
12 to 15 percent of the rna that's
present
in a given cell so not all the cell uh
we are only capturing a small fraction
of it
uh that gives a a representative picture
of the cell
to establish that we can indeed do
single cell library
and it's it's not a mixture from
different cells
we perform an experiment taking mouse
cell lines
cells from a muscle line and cells from
a human cell line
mix them together run dropsy and for the
most part after sequencing when we align
uh each cellular barcode to the mouse
and the human genome
we see that all of them align uh
to the human genome or the mouse genome
uh specifically
mostly uh there is a small
scattering of dots in the center i'm
looking at
the panel to the bottom left there's a
small scattering of drops uh
or cells that is uh
have transcripts from both them in the
human genome
and that can be con droplet
both a human and a mouse cell got
encapsulated and processed together so
it it shares
uh shares the same barcode the number of
uh such cells would be double that so
if uh let's say this kind of uh uh
scatters are about two percent of the
total number of cells
are number of doublets or
that have two cells would be four
percent for example
another uh i think to point out
in a in a poisson loading uh uh
framework in that we load the cell
concentration and the beep concentration
or we adjust them in such a way that
there is
uh only one the probability of getting
one cell
and one bead is pretty high that means a
lot of these droplets are empty
uh and a lot of these droplets have one
cell no bead
or the other way around now we can
uh depending on these loading
concentration you are going to have
uh duplet rates change so for example we
talked about a two percent
uh or four percent doublet rate in the
previous slide
you can change the loading concentration
with a higher cell
loading concentration you're going to
get a higher fraction
of drop it's going to be a shorter quick
and dirty experiment you can
lower this cell loading concentration
you can get a clear
uh a more cleaner experiment
and this is done uh
by by choice by what your experiment uh
requires for example
so we see in these different panels by
changing the cell concentration the
loading cell concentration
you can uh decrease the number of uh
dots that are present and it's not
only the loading uh concentration that
would be the most
ideal situation if you have cells that
are
uh leaky for example that's going to
give you
ambient noise that could give you a more
uh
uh even mixing of uh
of these scattered plot uh scatters in
the
species mixing plot or if you have cells
that are sticky
then you might have chances a higher
chance of getting a human cell
stuck to a mouse cell and you can get a
higher number
for example uh what are these
kind of experiments useful for they
are good for looking at complex tissues
uh by looking at their rna expression
we applied this technique to mouse
retina
for uh very young mice and we see that
uh
uh for the most part the
the bioinformatic analysis yields us
these uh
cell types that can be matched to what
is already known for the mouse retina
so for example these these blobs
actually are color coded by the picture
to the left
um so this kind of plotting is called a
tsne plot there are other ways of doing
this
principle component is one way that is
going to show you
the principal components one and two two
and three tsne is a
higher dimensional representation it
shows you
many more components it captures many
more components there are
a very commonly used uh
type called umap but what it shows you
is this high dimensional
idea so this is about 10 000 cells with
uh 20 000 um genes
um potentially 20 000 genes expressed so
this is a pretty high dimension data
you can uh show this or represent this
in uh
in in two dimension and the cells that
are uh closer together they cluster by
similarities so all the cells
let's say in this navy blue blob they
are going to have very similar
properties and are going to be
that much different from the purple blob
for example
and uh in our initial experiments we
were able to run 50 000 cells
approximately and uh get about 40 uh
different uh
cell types uh so that was a pretty uh
big jump in uh the number of cells we
could process
and also the number of uh different cell
types that we could uh
capture in an experiment now one of the
uh challenges in using uh
dropsy for any kind of single cell
rna-seq
is that we are going to
have this problem of cell type
dissociation where
um
where uh the quality of the experiment
depends on the cell health
or the the dissociation quality
now if we were to work with frozen
tissues or postmodern tissues the cell
quality is already pretty low
and that leads to a lot of rna leakage
and
rna degradation and that does not uh
that is not very conducive for uh the
dropseek protocol that i had talked to
you before
so i'm going to talk about a very very
similar complementary technique
also a droplet single nucleus rna-seq or
drunk seek
that allows us to work with a little bit
uh
harder to work with tissues so this was
uh
developed to look at brain tissue we
remember we
looked at retina which is not really
brain tissue
but we were very interested in looking
at the complex uh cell types in the
brain
uh the way to do that was to look at
the nuclear rna and we look at nuclear
rna because the cellular the cytoplasmic
rna was not accessible to us we couldn't
generate a good enough single cell
suspension
because all the neurons are very well
uh uh are clustered or tied
uh to each other by the axons and the
dendrites
so it's very difficult to make a clean
single cell suspension so
the choice was to work with the uh
single nuclei the nuclei is much more
intact
as rna it is the rna that got recently
transcribed and is in the process of
going
out from the nucleus to the cytoplasm
and
it is uh similar it is representative of
the cell
but not quite the same so in
as in comparison to the single cells
rna you are going to get a smaller
fraction this is
so roughly a tenth of what you would
expect from the cytoplasm or the whole
cell in in general
because most of the rna is present in
the cell
in the cytoplasm um and this is
a very recently transcribed rna so
you're going to get a
pretty recent snapshot of what the cell
just uh did or what the cell is uh
transcribing at that
particular uh point of time uh it can
also
be uh not completely uh
formed it can be uh it is nascent it's
it
it might be missing uh the
polyadenylated tail
it could still have its intronic regions
so
uh to point out in the lower panels
in in a single nuclei rna-seq we roughly
capture
half the number of rna present in the
present in the um we capture roughly
half the number of rna that we typically
capture with a single cell uh
rna-seq and this is the the fraction is
a little bit higher
in comparison if it had a tenth of rna
we capture higher number of
uh genes and that's because of the way
the
protocol worked out i'm not going to go
into the detail
but if you compare the single cell
rna with the single new nuclei rna that
there is a much higher prevalence of
non-coding rna in the nuclear rna
and mitochondrial rna from the cellular
rna or the
whole cell rna which is expected and
if we were to look at which particular
regions these rna
mapped to it would be on the
um uh most there would be a smaller
fraction would map to the exonic region
uh relatively higher fraction maps to
the intronic region
cytogenic regions and so on and so forth
so this allowed us uh
the single nuclea allowed us to
uh um adult
brain even though they we weren't able
to get good single cell suspension
out of uh brain tissue adult brain
tissue we were able to get single nuclei
and based on the nuclear rna signature
we could
identify cell types uh from this uh
protocol
and i should also point out that this
tissue was came from the gtex
project and it was archival tissue also
so not only for
adult adult brain tissue but this was
good for
frozen samples that were sitting
for about five six years in the
in the in the freezer before we ran this
so the cell quality was pretty
compromised
to start with and we were still able to
make it work which was very gratifying
and
opened up our options for
uh looking at many difficult to work
with
tissues i should point out that if you
take any one of these big blobs
so for example in the tsne plot to the
left here
the green blob and if we perform
hierarchical clustering on these
um you can find out even uh
finer structures in a given blob and uh
identify finer subtypes within a given
cell type in the tissue
and even though we see from the plot to
the
bottom right even if they have different
numbers of
uh rna captured for a given cell type
it is it clusters by cell type and not
by the number of rna
captured it's also something to note
that different cells
do have different number of rna
expressed
uh we are applying a single cell
and single nuclei rnac do a bunch of
different
experiments one of them is
benchmarking these two techniques using
human ipsc-derived cardiomyocytes this
was done
for the human cell atlas and
what we did was we sampled cells from
different
points of the differentiation process it
was
a 15 day differentiation process
by day seven uh adult uh cardiomyocytes
are already
established we take day zero to all the
way to day uh
15 and
we samples by using both dropsy single
cell
and bronx single nuclei one of the
things to note here again
is that there is a lot of intronic reads
and the single nuclei data that is not
present in the
seed data and that is because we are
working with mature rna in drop c
versus uh pre-spliced rna in drunk c
and again the number of rna that we get
from
intronic regions is much higher and we
use this kind of intronic reads into our
pipeline now
to increase the number of rna that we
get
uh and that helps us improve the data
quality
we did that on uh these uh uh
cardiomyocytes differentiating ipscs
into cardiomyocytes and
see that for both drop seek and drug
seek we capture the major cell types
uh from day 0 to 15
and that
the there are different uh types of
cardiomyocytes certain variations in
cardiomyocyte
cardiomyocytes that are uh generated by
these differentiation protocol
we also see that uh these two techniques
are pretty good in
capturing the fraction of cells um
um in in each of these uh time points
and
that was also very gratifying to see
and i'm going to uh point out that this
was possible because these cells were
growing on a plate it is
much more difficult if you were to eat a
primary lots of biases uh generated
uh tissued in itself but at least using
these two techniques
there wasn't any technical artifact that
was giving different uh
uh cell fractions and using
uh again uh sophisticated bioinformatic
techniques looking at
their expression we can construct a
a trajectory uh in which the cells
differentiate
and we can not only get
this recreate the differentiation
process into the major
cardiomyocyte types that we
see in our both these techniques give a
very similar results
i should also point out that there's
this very small fraction of cells that
the single cell uh protocol uh it
manages to
identify that is not identified by the
single nuclei protocol
and with that i am going to stop my
presentation
alrighty awesome we are all set
and uh you did a great job that caught
me off guard for a second i was tracking
with your slides and then you
um i thought you had probably happy
presentation left
that's correct i i you know i
i couldn't have covered everything i
decided i wanted to
uh tell a story and i think this is
where it stops there is another
part that you know i could have gone
into but
there isn't enough time i i
wonder if i could add the uh one more
slide which is the
acknowledgement slide but we can also uh
cut the presentation here
yeah if you want to go ahead and jump
over to the acknowledgement slide we can
record that real quick while we're still
on
let me just make a quick note for that
before we start the last slide there one
second
so we were in slide 17 and now we're
here on 30.
yes yeah that was like yeah
okay i made a note so what i'm going to
do is i'm just going to count you
down from five real quick um so we can
cut for the acknowledgement side and
then you can get started after i count
you down
alrighty starting in five four three
two
last but not the least i would like to
acknowledge the people who did all this
work
this is not possible to do such a huge
amount of work
uh without a big team
drawing from device fabrication
molecular biology
biologists uh computer computational
scientists
and we have uh a very big group working
on this
uh a lot of the work that i talked about
today
was done in my postdoc at the broad
institute
but a uh current position at argon
and uh uchicago i have my group
to the um the names are listed to the
left
it's my this is my group outing a
picture to the right
uh very good colleagues without whose
help i cannot function
and some colleagues in
not in chicago who also participate in
other projects that relate with
dropseek and wrong seat and of course uh
funding agencies
um that um keep our
lab running thank you
okay great all set so pretty much from
here i'll just do some
quick editing on the front and back ends
and then i'll work on
stitching together where you finished
off on slide 17 with your
acknowledgement slide and then we'll be
all ready to go
for the presentation on wednesday
thank you of course any other questions
for me before we wrap
up um not really but
uh so all the things that i said today
um
i talked about today up to slide 17 it's
all published so it should be okay to
uh share oh perfect okay i'll go ahead
and update the note then
that's helpful um perfect so i'll go
ahead and just
use up to slide 17 and um i'll make sure
not to use any of those other slides
thank you all righty well we will talk
to you soon thank you for your time we
appreciate it
thanks tyler it was a big help have a
good rest of your day
you too bye bye